Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt.
Und mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle die heute zuhören und das sind unter anderem ganz viele Gäste hier beim 35 C3 Chaos Communication Congress ich sag hallo.
Ich sag dir seit Tagen und vor allem seit Stunden und,
insbesondere seit Minuten an mich immer alle so was essen da ist und so und was soll denn das jetzt alles und.
Schönes das haben wir vor zwei Minuten Online.
Mache jetzt und so weiter ja ja eben ihr seid alle so aufgeregt aber ich habe ein anderes Verhältnis zu Lampenfieber.
Ich wollte ich wollte ich wollte mal was neues machen und das schon richtig lange geht euch gar nicht vorstellen darf ich habe den den Twitter-Account für diesen Podcast habe ich,
2015 registriert in dem Moment als mir als mir dann endlich die Idee kam wie ich denn das mal nenne was ich denn da eigentlich die ganze Zeit vorhabe,
und,
das möchte ich zu Beginn mal erklären dann versteht ihr das nämlich vielleicht auch als ich mein ja schon ganz lange Podcast und so und eigentlich habe ich überlegt mache ich ja eigentlich nur zwei na ja vielleicht zweieinhalb verschiedene Podcast.
Klingt jetzt gleich erstmal ein bisschen abwegig aber wenn es mal überlegst ich rede halt mit langen langen mit Leuten über ein Thema von A bis Z.
In verschiedenen Kanälen und Bezeichnung aber eigentlich mit mal ehrlich war sitzt immer das gleiche also immer das gleiche Prinzip und.
Muss ja nicht schlecht sein.
Nein ich habe dich gesagt das schlechteste nur so was ist ur und
dann habe ich halt so Gesprächsrunde und da bin ich aber dann irgendwie auch dann ist es halt auch irgendwie nicht das eigene Ding weil das halt mal ja dann auch eben mit dem ganzen Team selbst normal das ein bisschen die Regler schiebt und also Geschichten und,
irgendwie fehlte mir so ein bisschen so ein Outlet wo ich einerseits mal wusste wie einerseits mein Ding ist,
Bauch auch in dieser Frage Situation bin ich ja eigentlich gar nicht da weil ich frag ja nur so ne und.
Deswegen muss da irgendwie was her und dann überlegt so wie man damit irgendwie auch ordentlich Impex machen kann.
Habe ich mich daran erinnert dass wir immer alle erzählen seit Jahren irgendwie ne Windel richtig Reichweite haben willst dann musst du Kaffee machen.
Radio und soll es selber ob der Hitze nachts mehr okay alles klar,
UKW also sind wir jetzt hier und reden über unsere kleine Welt und ich habe dann gleich zu Beginn mal zwei Gäste reingeholt mit die ich schon ganz lange mal sowas machen wollte nämlich.
Nicolas nicholasville und den Reinhard Reinhard Renfordt.
Hallo.
Ich muss schon mal ich muss mal ganz kurz dazu sagen es so viel haben wir zu diesen Formaten vorher noch nicht gehört ne wir sitzen auch genauso wie ihr hier und wir sind ein bisschen überrascht und können natürlich hier zu Hause nicht mehr absagen.
Ich habe ich habe vor 30 Minuten noch gesagt selbst für mich ist das unglaublich unangenehm wenig Vorbereitung.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen wie ich mich fühle also ich echt ich stand noch nie auf einer Bühne wo ich überhaupt nicht wusste was auf mich zukommt aber gut,
schauen wir mal was das gibt müssen uns diese diese die geile Geschichte vergessen zu erzählen dass du dir auch noch die Domain gesichert hast von UKW. FM das ist mein Coupe.
Vermutlich auch 2015 ne also wenn man immer wäre das Radio ist spät dran oder oder hat den Schuss nicht gehört da da wird's dann irgendwie dann doch auffällig der ist schon sehr geil ja.
Ja und was ich halt und hier darf ich halt jetzt alles machen.
Ja was mich ein bisschen beruhen ruhig ist du willst alles machen 2015 registrierte Domain und dann brauchst du drei Jahre um irgendwas zu machen und uns verzweifelt einzuladen das kann ich ja sonst nur von Reinhard Büchern.
Und was draus geworden Bestseller.
So bevor das hier wieder in einem methodisch inkorrekt show umschlägt,
muss ich euch weil ist ja mein Podcast und den kennt ja auch noch keiner muss ich euch an die auch noch mal vorstellen also aus meiner Perspektive seid ihr halt vor allem Podcast Kollegen Reinert das irgendwann mal beim hörertreffen aufgelaufen ich glaube das war in,
in Essen genau in Essen in diesem Unperfekthaus ne genau.
Habe ich auch noch sehr gut dran.
Und hat so I tät ja wir machen da mal was mit wissen,
das hat ja dann eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert bei euch so also ihr seid ja dann durchaus in Regelmäßigkeit und Beständigkeit geraten und wart auch selber so ein bisschen,
überrasch glaube ich auch von dem was passiert ist.
Ja wir sind da immer sehr gern die Geschichte werden sie die ersten Folgen gemacht und haben uns immer tierisch gefreut als wir in unseren Feed Statistiken gesehen haben so,
krass und für 100 Leute das ist mehr als vier Leute persönlich kennen das ist mehr als diese die mein Bruder hört das deine Frau,
und die Freunde von uns an wirklich zurecht Leute die es interessiert was wir hier machen und jedesmal wenn es Anime so einen kleinen Sprung gemacht haben das kann immer bei irgendwelchen Events oder wenn wir meinen Armen Podcast zu das waren gerade
hast du das erste mal hier hier beim Kongress waren bzw dann noch in Hamburg und im Sendezentrum unter der Rolltreppe unsere kleine physikinstrumente schon gemacht haben dann wird das halt immer mehr und immer mehr
und so das hat uns dadurch auch selbst ein bisschen überrascht.
Meine lieblings Erinnerung an dich und Tim ist wir waren dann relativ schnell beim ersten Podcaster treffen die ist damals und pppw glaube ich ne oder.
Jaja podlove Podcaster wird.
Genau und da hast du so ein bisschen den Leuten Beistand gegeben wenn wenn ihre Podcast und bisschen,
zusammen gefrickelt waren und Reinhard hat eine Frage gestellt und ich saß hinter Reinhard oder eigentlich wenn ich das gewusst hätte ich euch das Bild mitgebracht weil das ist eins meiner Lieblingsfotos gesagt hinter Reinert also irgendwie so da unten bei euch und der
da er hier der Stand zu guckt so in seine Richtung und Reinhard stellte Frage ebenfalls völlig dilettantisches weil unser Podcast war so zusammen geklöppelt,
du so fassungslos warst du guckst ihn an und sagt er kann doch nicht dein Ernst sein dieses Bild habe ich fotografiert ist meine Liebste Erinnerung einer meiner ersten Erinnerungen wo wir dich kennengelernt habe jetzt mal hier.
Oh das war am Anfang wirklich sehr dilettantisch zusammen gehämmert also wir haben weder den Publisher noch ein eigenes WordPress unsere unsere Daten lagen bei archives.org also.
Du redest von dem von dem Server Setup nicht von dem von nicht von der Sendung.
Nein nein nein nicht von der Sendung sondern Wert von der Technik drumrum.
Ich habe dass ich glaube das hatte ich besonders frustriert dass wir im Prinzip wissen worüber wir sprechen aber die Art und Weise wie es technisch dahinter aussieht ganze Zeit jede Woche in die Luft gehen das hatte ich glaube ich fertig gemacht aber okay.
Das hat sich nicht geändert.
Bevor wir hier wie immer so schön sagt ins Plaudern kommt vielleicht auch kurz abschließend,
was was OKW vielleicht so sein könnte und warum ist das jetzt auch auf einmal gibt ne also ihr habt ja nicht eure Sendung also eurer Show oder was auch immer hier hätte entstehen können für dieses Jahr,
was ist abgesagt also gar nicht erst in Angriff genommen da wart ihr sozusagen frei,
hatte mir so okay alles klar dann müssen wir jetzt mal die Sendung machen die wir noch nie gemacht haben und
das war dann so ein bisschen auf der der der der Punkt wo ich mir gedacht habe okay alles klar dann dann geht's jetzt wohl los mit UKW na weil du die gesagt das Format ist seit 3 Jahren im Prinzip startbereit,
er in den Kanälen und ja wenn man nicht irgendwann mal anfängt dann wird halt auch nie was ganz.
Warum guckst du mich dabei an.
Aya.
Äpfel für für die Leute die schon mal hier sitzen die erste Deadline die bei Amazon steht könnt ihr vergessen das klappt nie im Leben.
Tschuldigung UKW.
Genau außerdem außerdem ist es bisschen auch ein Dank für die Unterstützung die ich so im letzten Jahr
vermehrt erhalten habe und auch da wollte ich natürlich dann drauf antworten das hatte ich auch schon angekündigt
dass ich dann immer so ganz blumig Dinge in Vorbereitung habe und so weiter und irgendwann kommt dann auch ne und außerdem werde ich halt jetzt demnächst mal längere Zeit außerhalb von Deutschland sein,
und dann eben auch den Vorteil haben hier bei UKW mit einer Tradition zu brechen also einer meiner Tradition zu brechen dass ich ja eigentlich,
nahezu immer mit wenigen Ausnahmen Podcast nur in Präsenz machen also zu Misty interviews ist bei mir ganz ganz ganz ganz wichtig die Art wie ich Interviews.
Mache und machen will funktioniert nicht,
es funktioniert in so Formaten wie Logbuch Netzpolitik mit Linus weil Jesus und ich halt schon wieder ein altes Ehepaar irgendwie schon wissen wie wir aufeinander reagieren da geht das alles hat dazu eine professionelle Ebene,
mach dir ja auch mittlerweile ihr kennt das so und aber mit Leuten halt auch mal remote seid auch das allererste Mal zu sprechen,
ist schon noch mal ein bisschen was anderes und erfordert auch noch mal so eine ganz andere steht also auf sowas bin ich machen und unsere kleine Welt ist einfach nur so der lockere Versuch,
zu reflektieren was gerade so passiert na also auch aktueller zu sein Sachen einzugehen manchmal vielleicht Sachen die einen schon immer interessiert haben aber manchmal eben vielleicht auch einfach Sachen die passiert jetzt keine Nachrichten in dem eigentlichen Sinne,
also Vorgänger Dinge so was weiß ich jetzt kippen irgendwie die Börsen ab so man könnte sich ja mal,
darüber unterhalten so muss man sowas ernst nehmen was ist denn das überhaupt ECO ne jetzt gleich wieder so mega
CAE die Börse oder so draus zu machen einfach um das mal irgendwie,
Wetterhorn so ja also das ist eigentlich das was ich jetzt vorab noch mal kurz sagen wollte das ganze ist dann nicht nicht vielleicht ich regelmäßig aber wir öfter als selten,
zumindest ne und da ich den Produktionsaufwand insgesamt etwas geringer einschätze denke ich mal wird das schon irgendwie hinhauen.
Ja so warum wollte ich euch sprechen wenn ich das so genau wüsste also ihr habt,
ihr habt so.
Ich glaube es.
Ja ich muss dann auch wieder.
Hat noch jemand ein Bier.
Ja genau ich brauche trinken wir das irgendwie kennt jemand noch mal so ein Premium Pils irgendwo von.
Das Verlassen auf Menschen ist Verlass.
Im Moment bist bislang zeigt er die Flasche nur alles hat mal wieder was Besonderes aus Osnabrück.
Oldenburger Oldenburg 4 vielen Dank für diesen Opel.
Das ist eine 5 Liter Flasche.
Hat jemand Pappbecher.
Hat jemand Gläser.
Ja mehr für mich.
Du bist hast du Lampenfieber.
Extrem.
Ich glaube weil ich einen relativ hohen Anspruch an mich selbst habe und den versucht zu erfüllen und deswegen,
selbst bei relativ kleinen also ich war heute hier als beispielsweise und zwar zum ersten Mal,
wir alt sind so die Menschen die hier so die Ansagen machen und jetzt könnte man ja sagen der Mensch steht regelmäßig auf Bühnen und redet dann auch zwei Stunden drei Stunden mit seinem Kollegen und er müsste nicht nervös sein aber ich bin schrecklich nervös weil ich weil ich meinen Job
gut machen will weil ich nicht versagen will wahrscheinlich.
Ja aber hilft dir das.
Ich glaube bis zum aber ich sollte wahrscheinlich sagen ja,
bedingungslos ja weil es mich immer wieder dahin bringen dass ich mich gut vorbereite
und deswegen mir gehaltvoll ja wirklich Gedanken machen was ich machen würde was ich tun will das jetzt bei mir weil muss muss man ja nicht so viel vorbereiten aber beispielsweise wenn wir uns dann wieder irgendwo hinstellen und was tun,
dann machen wir es schon relativ und mache mir schon viele Gedanken was wir zeigen wollen warum wir es zeigen wollen ob es ankommt ob es nicht ankommt ja ich ringe da schon sehr mit mir.
Was würde denn passieren wenn das nicht vorbereitet wär sind wirklich anders.
Undenkbar dass ich mich bis bis gerade und denkbare ich mich auf eine Bühne setzen würde ohne vorbereitet zu sein,
ja ich weiß es ist einfach schon Dennis konzeptionelle nicht denkbar weil ich eine Idee haben will wenn ich irgendwo mich hinsetze und und etwas in Migros spreche oder mich auf eine Bühne stell will will ich ein Konzept haben will ich wissen was ist die
Botschaft was will ich damit gesagt haben.
Deswegen ist schon schon der Grundgedanke spontan irgendwo mich hinzustellen kaum denkbar.
Du bist doch der Anlass.
Hey,
ja ja ich bin da hat sich ein bisschen anders das ist aber auch mit der mit der Zeit so gewachsen also das habe ich hier zum Großteil glaube ich auch nicht was verdanken
ich hatte früher tatsächlich viel Lampenfieber also sofort Regener Uni oder Vorträge in der Schule damals noch gar nicht grausam als wir dann so Kinder Unikram gemacht haben und ich gemerkt ob das auch echt Spaß machen kann weil irgendwann mal der Moment ist
Opfer der an dem Niklas krank war und ich abends allein vor 800 Kindern stehen musste,
aber der Kinder-Uni dass irgend so ein Knoten geplatzt ist jetzt so eine Plattitüde aber das irgendwie,
mittlerweile ist mir vollkommen egal ob ich vorbereitet bin oder nicht so ein bisschen Lampenfieber ja wenn wenn es irgendwie was ist was mir sehr wichtig ist
mache ich mir auch Gedanken oder so bei mir reicht eine grobe Idee,
aber ich ich lebe häufig bei vielen Sachen gerade so oft bin und sowieso in dieser Philosophie was das schlimmste was passieren kann und dann überlege ich mir was das schlimmste ist und denkt dann,
wenn das wirklich Eintritt der hat so schlimm also ist eine,
so also im schlimmsten Fall werde ich hier jetzt also für heute zumeist das schlimmste was passieren könnte die werden ausgeruht und raus gejagt oder so denk ich mir ja ist kacke ist vielleicht auch noch in der Woche kacke.
Aber ist ja Tims Nummer.
Nee das auch.
Jetzt.
Nein aber es ist ich fahr ich versuche ich versuche nach Möglichkeit mit sowas gelassen umzugehen und mir keinen Druck dabei zu machen oder möglichst wenig Druck natürlich ist das nicht immer hilfreich wäre manchmal natürlich durchaus
gut ordentlich vorbereitet sein oder besser vieles geht aber irgendwie später also kann man mit Spontanität lösen solangs halbwegs funktioniert
und weiß ich ich habe so viele andere Probleme in meinem Leben darf ich da nicht noch eins dazu packen möchte.
Was würdest du denn sagen was deine Rolle ist.
Meine Rolle comic relief.
Ja keine Ahnung mein mein meinte jetzt für heute Abend oder.
Nee nee so also generell auch jetzt gar nicht mal ganz mal auf methodisch inkorrekt bezogen sondern.
Deine Rolle in dem Moment wo du präsentierst oder quasi so vor anderen in welcher Öffentlichkeit auch immer Bühne Podcast et cetera quasi da bist.
Was.
Was man also meine Rolle in dem Moment oder meine aufgabe.
Deine Funktion.
Das hängt sehr sehr sehr stark davon ab was ich mache also wenn ich wenn ich beispielsweise bei Zumba zum Vortrag irgendwo
bin wo ich Leute für für Wissenschaftskommunikation in die begeister danke schön ich habe zwar letztens in killen Vortrag gehalten bei so einer Summers,
zum Thema Wissenschaftskommunikation in Form von Podcasts von Science Slam Vorträgen von Büchern und ähnlichen und er wurde nebenbei,
da habe ich dann da habe ich da weiß ich ich möchte eine Nachricht rüberbringen und zwar genau angepasst auf die Leute die da sitzen den Leuten dort das waren hauptsächlich,
so Leute die in also Doktoranden wieder Gewissen haben denen euch wollte ich irgendwie nahebringen geht raus rede mit den Leuten über das was sie macht weil das was ihr macht.
Unglaublich interessant für viele Menschen auch wenn er es nicht,
aber wenn erst ordentlich runterbrechen den Leuten erklärt was dir macht das ist gar nicht so kompliziert und so schlimm sondern erklärt den Leuten dass die finden das interessant und das wollte ich den Leuten näher bringen dass sie auch den Mut dazu haben halt die Sachen wirklich so einfach zu machen dass es jeder versteht weil viele sagen dann ja man darf das nicht trivialisieren und ich wollte den Leuten Halt
näher bringen dass es nur diese diese Einstellung man darf das nicht trivialisieren ist so ziemlich das schlimmste was man als Wissenschaftler machen kann
weil man sollte die Leute irgendwie in irgendeiner Form erstmal versuchen abzuholen um sie für das Thema zu begeistern das wollte ich den Menschen dort
mir bringen und da habe ich halt als meine Aufgabe ist gesehen diese Message rüberzubringen wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
RV Kindern irgendwie eine Physik Vorlesung mach ist das anders die versuche ich für die Wissenschaft an sich zu begeistern vielleicht ein bisschen wie eine Zaubershow mit Experimenten oder so wenn ich wiederum in wissenschaftlichen Vortrag halt also ihr was Ernsthaftes im Sinne von meiner Arbeit vorstelle die ich irgendwie 5 Jahre lang im Labor gemacht habe ist das wieder eine andere Rolle die verkörper also die Rolle die ich
in dem Moment auf einer Bühne verkörpert hängt immer sehr stark davon ab welche message ich vor also
rüberbringen möchte wem ich sie rüberbringen möchte das ist auch ganz wichtig wärst das Publikum und in welchem in welchem Rahmen ist das irgendwie also.
Ja wenn du Rolle verkörpern sagst dann kriegt er so ein bisschen wie Theater ne eigentlich eine Spritze ja von deiner Botschaft was dein Ziel ist so ne ich meine die Funktion also in welche welche Funktion,
ipso in diesem Spiel aus damit diese Ziele,
erreicht werden ist? Bisschen kompliziert in Wismar so auf meine was ich denke was so meine Funktion manchmal,
ist ne das man ebenso zeigen durch Fragen so eine Art Gedanken Katalysator für.
Ja sie klingt mich so an einer Stelle in die Kommunikation ein und versuch halt irgendwie in beide Richtungen sowohl mit dem input als auf dem Output irgendwie klarzukommen.
Zu kompliziert.
Ich glaube also ich gehe jetzt mal davon außer die Frage nicht nur an reinhard war sondern an unsere anderen Spider irgendwie ich glaube.
Also natürlich die Rolle wir sind Wissenschaftskommunikation sicherlich wir wollen über Wissenschaft sprechen aber das wird uns Wiki am wichtigsten ist ist diese diese Barriere zwischen zwischen der dem Elfenbeinturm und und dem interessierten.
Also der interessierten Öffentlichkeit irgendwie kleiner zu machen wir wollen so reden wie wir reden wir wollen
Experimente machen die daneben gehen und uns da drüber kaputt lachen oder uns daraus dann lernen warum das das gescheitert ist also diese diese diese enorme diese Distanz zwischen Wissenschaftlern und und der Öffentlichkeit die wollen wir
kleiner da.
Stoppe möchte anderen Menschen unsere Welt zeigen,
also das was du was unsere Welt ist was für uns wichtig ist was für uns vielleicht auch selbstverständlich ist was unsere alt unsere Denkmuster sind unsere Welt unsere unser Weltverständnis das möchten wir irgendwie Menschen näher bringen.
Auch die die Sachen die wir dann machen sie wär forschen die diese Entdeckungen die da gemacht haben sehr moderne Entdecker eigentlich die das sind auch wirklich spannende Geschichte,
dummerweise haben Wissenschaftler verlernt zu kommunizieren wir Wissenschaftler kommunizieren nur noch in Wissenschaft.
Lepan in einer Sprache die nicht verstanden wird die eigentlich
ist Kommunikation von Wissenschaftlern zu Wissenschaftlern und das finde ich eigentlich bisschen schade weil das war denen unserer born passiert ist extrem spannend und dann würden wir gerne runterbrechen das würde mir gerne so erzählen dass es verstanden wird und das ist sich ja nicht so ein bisschen unsere Roller auch Dinge
erinner in die Worte zu kleiden die verstanden werden sicherlich auch ein bisschen auszuschmücken sicherlich ein bisschen Geschichtenerzählen sicherlich ihn auch ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen gucken zu lassen.
Teilhaben zu lassen also irgendwie also ich mein das machen wir uns am Podcast der genauso also bei mir bringt man es auch wir lassen die Leute nicht nett wie erklären nicht einfach nur Paypal sondern Großteil
von mir kriegst auch dass die Leute in unserem Leben in irgendeiner Form teilhaben und zwar in unserem Leben als Wissenschaftler irgendwie im Labor als Leute also jetzt über die sechs Jahre schon bei mir als jemand der gar nicht mehr in der Uni arbeitet sondern sich so irgendwie durchschlägt,
dass die Leute ja nee nee nicht schon wieder.
Nee reicht erstmal,
aber nebenbei was was auch noch ein großer Teil unserer genau aus dieser Sicht unseres unser Tätigkeit ist es eben auch Fragen beantworten E-Mails beantworten ist alles Dinge die,
sieht man nicht so die aber parallel zu diesem Podcast laufen also persönliche Fragen,
Naturphänomene die versucht werden zu erklären dann von uns die uns gestellt werden oder auch einfach nur Fragen zum Studium die wir eben auch noch,
mit nicht unwesentlich Zeit nebenher beantworten aber weil es genau auch dieser Punkt ist den du ansprichst ne weißt du unsere Rolle und Rolle ist,
erreichbar zu sein und nicht irgendwo da ist eine Hochschule kann ich nicht rein gehen sondern
schreib uns eine E-Mail wir versuchen zu antworten ich würde ich würde behaupten wir haben bis jetzt alle E-Mails beantwortet vielleicht mal ein zwei nicht aber.
Imin in der Sendung oder als E-Mail.
Nee also E-Mail Mensch zu Mensch möglicherweise haben wir einzelne nicht beantwortet.
Wifi Viersen Dassow.
Ja
Datschwandt immer ne also manchmal sind manchmal kommt irgend kommende Woche so 2 Uhr oder so manchmal kommende Woche aber auch 15 bis 20 oder so also,
da kann das gerade wenn wir ein kontroverses Thema in der Sendung hatten kann das sehr viel in einer Woche werden wir mal sagen im Schnitt sind zwei sind in der Woche.
Ich weiß nicht aber die dein Problem ist nicht so sehr die Menge manchmal geht's halt auch schnell ne aber wenn,
wenn schon präzise physikalische Fragen kommen wirst du ja da auch ordentlich drauf antworten da musst du selber ein bisschen noch mal die textbooks rausholen da muss noch mal bisschen nachlesen.
Schonzeit.
Gar nicht umfasst noch die seriöse Arbeit im Vergleich zum Podcast weil er ja sehr viel Unterhaltung auch drin ist und Vorbereitung.
Auf jeden Fall also sag mal die Sendung ist Spaß die Vorbereitung Zusendung ist Arbeit ein bisschen und die,
die Arbeit drumrum ist extrem wichtig ist auch extrem befriedigend weil kriegen natürlich auch E-Mails wo du gesagt Chris ich bin durch eine harte Zeit gegangen letzte halbe Jahr habt ihr mich
durchgezogen das bedeutet ja einfach mehr als ja also ja David.
Also es sind schon teilweise sehr persönliche und sehr emotionale Nachrichten dabei also sei es jetzt als E-Mail Twitter oder sonst was
wo wo Leute und zahlt wirklich sowas sowas schreiben wie ich hier ich habe in den letzten zwei Jahren mit harten Depressionen gekämpft und euer Podcast war irgendwie sowas was mir Halt gegeben hat weil ich halt wusste ich kann alle zwei Wochen kann ich euch zu hören,
Sona uns also wenn du sowas siehst da das ist so schon als mir ging's mir so dass er zum Schluss erstmal weil du jetzt,
bewusst dass in dem Moment vor dem Podcast Masters also dass da Leute sind den das soviel bedeutet also mich hat das echt also.
Das Gatter tatsächlich eine Nachricht von jemanden der der mich mal persönlich angeschrieben hatte als ich auch gesagt hast du hier mir geht's halt nicht so gut weil ich auch weiß nicht zu viel zu viel um die Ohren hatte mit Dissertation meine Eltern waren krank und so weiter
Demi Lovato Soja mückenfalle genauso wenn ich ihn sie mal Probleme hast melde dich bei mir und genauso hatte ich in die Leute,
die mich mal also ich hatte mal ein Mädel bei einem hörertreffen nämlich immer mal so zur Seite genommen hat und zu mir meinte so,
hier ich habe dir in den letzten Wochen mein Podcast zugehört pass mal auf Dich auf mir ging's vor irgendwie drei Jahren genauso und ich bin da irgendwann mal abgeschmiert nämlich mal zurück die genau die gleiche Person
habe ich irgendwie ein Jahr später noch mal bei einer anderen Gelegenheit wieder getroffen ich habe sie nicht erkannt was mir halt leid tat aber was auch nicht verwunderlich ist wenn man tritt halt unglaublich viele Menschen jetzt noch nicht böse genommen aber sie hat sich noch mal bei mir bedankt
weil ich weil ich ihr halt damals zugehört habe und mir das auch zu Herzen oder haben auch später im Podcast noch mal erwähnt habe und sie hat meinte so
Wahrheit wird also ist halt was wichtiges was anderen Leuten auch hilft und mir Person also
wir machen den Podcast ja nicht nur für andere Menschen sondern für uns selbst auch also wir lernen unglaublich viel bei der Vorbereitung
uns also für mich ist das ein Großteil meines Lebens irgendwie auch geworden und mir hat das auch also mir selbst hat der Podcast auch so,
weil ihr setzt therapiert zu viel gesagt aber so in in Zeiten in Sinsbeck Kacke ging hat mir es trotzdem irgendwie geholfen so Struktur wie man so schön sagt.
Also heute deine geschriebenes Hirn auch noch erzählen weil die hat mich auch sehr bewegt da waren da keine E-Mail und da wurde gesagt da stand im Wesentlichen auch drin.
Wir sollen nie vergessen dass das Leuten wirklich viel bedeutet was wir machen und das sind Leute die die.
Das auch wirklich brauchen der letzte Satz dieser E-Mail war manchmal,
können Podcast Leben retten dieser Mensch war irgendwann so am Ende dass wir ihn so so hat er geschrieben ihn rausgezogen haben,
da muss ich mich hinsetzen da war ich da war war wirklich goosebumps dafür waren wir nie angetreten ne also wir wollten eigentlich was völlig anderes machen aber dieses diese Nummer Podcast an sich aber unsere Nummer dann auch hat hat er wieso.
Sonne wollen einen Stellenwert für manche Leute erreicht,
das war nie abzusehen ne und deswegen tue ich mir ein bisschen schwer wenn du mich fragst was ist eure Rolle so oder was ist eure wie wie hast du es gesagt also eure Funktion das ist so weit davon weg mittlerweile,
womit wir angetreten waren wir beide wollten nur Spaß haben wir wollten uns gesagt wird macht Spaß über Wissenschaft zu reden und damit waren wir angetreten und das ist etwas völlig anderes geworden immer noch unser Spaß aber eben auch.
Aber mehr es ist für viele Leute sowohl für uns.
Für uns hatte ich auch.
Flotte wir uns zuhören mehr geworden und es ist schwer zu greifen was mehr in diesem Fall bedeutet also.
Und manchmal können Podcast Leben retten das war ne Nummer okay das damit hatte ich nicht gerechnet oder wir nicht.
Da stellt sich die Frage was denn jetzt eigentlich die Funktion ist weil nur dieses ich erzähl mal was und habe Spaß dabei und mir doch egal ob die Leute das gut finden oder nicht.
Ist ja nicht ne ich habe auch gemerkt also wenn jemand dann gewinnt ja
nenne Öffentlichkeiten Öffentlichkeit die beide Seiten auch in gewisser Hinsicht etwas verstört nein sicherlich auch so die Ansprache mit ja Leute treten auf einen zu,
dann soll das so formulieren im Sinne von dass dieses Gefühl haben einen gut zu kennen klar weil ne da ist viel Informationen geflossen und diese Asymmetrie dieses Verhältnis ist halt irgendwie für beide Seiten auch irgendwie
Vietnam muss ja damit dann auch irgendwie klar, und dann merkt man auf einmal dass das genau in so einer Asymmetrie wo man,
das ging war gar nicht kennt trotzdem irgendwie nur auf aber eine Rolle Spiel von der man bis dahin auch noch überhaupt nichts wusste,
später weiß man dann sozusagen egal was mache auch solche Fälle sind dabei oder anders ausgedrückt man übernimmt,
Verantwortung die man eigentlich gar nicht haben wollte die man aber trotzdem hat weil man ja gemerkt hat.
Irgendwie bewegt das Ding.
Wirst du das ist meine Verantwortung und Wort mit den du was anfangen kannst in dem Zusammenhang.
Ehrlich gesagt im Moment noch nicht so.
Also also du und zwar so viel Spaß dass wir noch nie drüber nachgedacht haben aufzuhören also bevor wir sehen wer Sorge hat aber ich meine klar wenn man irgendwann sagen würde man hat jetzt keine Lust mehr dazu machen dann kämen möglicherweise
Tim möglicherweise solche Gedanken aber ich habe also ehrlich.
Also nicht nur Imbiss Telefon Verantwortung dass man es aufrechterhalten muss dann auch in dem was man sagt thematisiert oder wie man halt ne.
Ich glaube,
immer noch ich weiß nicht wann hat kannst kannst du aber zu sein ich finde wir sind immer noch sehr naiv so in dem wie wir das machen wir sitzen immer noch zusammen und reden da drüber also gibt wenig Momente wo wir mal wieder merken das hat Ding echt
groß geworden ist so also hier Kongress ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen da merkst du das groß geworden wenn man jetzt
Tickets für Sonne Liveshow verkaufte merkst du auch ok ist auf einmal da muss man mehr organisieren so muss ich auch mal irgendwie Gedanken um,
Finanzen machen wieso was verbucht wir damit man nicht irgendwie in Knast coiffant nicht nicht Wallert Reichtümer sind sondern einfach.
Witzig aber das ist leider so.
Nicht weil er ganz und gar nicht wild Reichtümer sind oder nur weil wenn ich irgendwann vor von Nichts stehen wollen
es ist schon größer geworden aber wir unser Podcast ist immer noch genauso naiv und spielerisch würde ich sagen Vivi bisher oder.
Ich glaube der Punkte an ist auch dass wir das in unserem Podcast sehr viel von uns als Persönlichkeiten drinsteckt www wir haben eigentlich
also dass ich tue vielleicht tue ich mich besser mit diesem bitte den Funktionsbegriff an der Stelle auch so schwer wir werden da nie groß drüber nachgedacht wir sind einfach wir wenn wir da über irgendwas reden
und vielleicht so Verantwortung.
Weiß ich nicht aber inwiefern wir Verantwortung dabei bewusst ist was mir schon bewusst ist in in letzter Zeit hin und wieder mal ist dass man eine gewisse Reichweite hat die man vielleicht mal für was Gutes benutzen kann also,
meine liebsten ist kurz vor Weihnachten Aktion auf Twitter halt aufgefallen die heißt eine Sorge weniger wo.
Wo Leute sich als freiwillig melden und irgendwie Kinder zu beschenken wo die Familie vielleicht ist viel Geld haben und so weiter und da ich das auch Skins also aus meiner Kindheit selber halt sehr gut kenne das war halt eine Familie kein Geld haben so weiter hat mich die Aktion hat sich persönlich berührt und ich fand es wichtig und habe es halt im Podcast erwähnt
darüber geredet dass ich die Aktion super finde und dass ich die sehr unterstützenswert finde und die Leute diesen Twitter-Account betreiben haben uns eine Woche später geschrieben so
danke dass ihr es erwähnt habe,
wir haben ihn geplatzt ein paar 100 Follower mehr und plötzlich Spenden und hier ist an irgendwie zwei Tage später alles so in Anführungszeichen explodiert ist jetzt nicht dass er tausende Leute waren aber im Vergleich zum Rauschen von sonst hat es bei dir so ein Knick gegeben in dem Moment
und das hat die Leute halt unglaublich gefreut mich hat das auch gefreut weil es halt ne
wie ich finde gute Sache war und meine dem Moment dann doch schon so merkt so,
dein Mann hat eine Reichweite mit der man was bewegen kann wenn es nur Kleinigkeiten also eine Kleinigkeit aber irgendwie finde ich trotzdem toll in dem Moment es ist aber nicht so darf ich,
stimmt wenn ich in ein Mikrofon rede mir die ganze Zeit Gedanken mache kann ich das jetzt so sagen oder sollte ich das jetzt oben muss ich da irgendwas beachten weil ich es weil ich halt irgendeine Form von Verantwortung habe und da vorher mal gefälligst drüber nachdenken sollte
das ist ein älteres möchte ich auch gar nicht.
Aber das macht es hat für uns auch relativ einfach und deswegen machst du es auch noch Spaß also das was uns beide hörertreffen am häufigsten gesagt wird ist ihr seid ja wirklich so erst nehmen wir mal als Kompliment.
Vielleicht denke dass das so eine gewisse Wahrhaftigkeit an der Stelle auch wichtig ist ne also da du dieses Ding an der Stelle.
Zeigt sich auch das immer glaube ich auch auf einer Linie so,
die Besonderheit von Podcast als Format sondern sicherlich etwas was jetzt nicht überall so der Fall ist damit will ich nicht sagen dass man auf YouTube nicht auch so sein kann wie man ist oder so aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt so die die Regel während deshalb
bei meiner Wahrnehmung hat Podcast ja selten so ist das Leute mal anders sind als ihr eigentlich sind im Podcast,
wobei wir natürlich auch ganz interessantes warum das eigentlich so ist.
Das hat so ein Teil davon hängt glaube ich mit mit dauert zusammen also ich würde zumal Spiel weil also so ein Podcast ist ja ja,
kann man wieder über dauert diskutieren wie lange darf ein Podcast sein ein guter Podcast ist 60 Minuten lang
also irgendwas jetzt fünf Minuten lang ist oder fünf Stunden geht oder was auch immer Podcast sollten ja in irgendeiner Form H-Milch.
Staatsminister so meiner Auffassung nach irgendwie halbwegs hier und da mal halbwegs regelmäßig erscheinen und nicht irgendwie mal fünf Jahre nicht und dann mal wieder
sondern irgendwie wenn man wenn man irgendwie ein Format hat wo man eine Message Ort wo mehr über irgendwas reden sollte zum Essen wieder
bei uns also unserer Erfahrung ist dass Kontinuität rennen relativ wichtiger Faktor ist also dass man kontinuierlich irgendwas macht
das ist bei Podcast ja meist etwas was du tatsächlich eine gewisse Länge hat und wenn man so das durchschnittliche YouTube wieder sich anguckt,
da kann man ganz gut glaube ich noch eine Rolle spielen weil es irgendwie zwar auch einmal die Woche oder mehrmals die Woche was erscheint aber das meistens so 10 Minuten Clips sind wo man eine Rolle verkörpern kann mir würde es unglaublich schwer fallen drei Stunden am Stück eben noch Rolle zu spielen
und die auch immer wieder zu spielen wenn ich in einen Podcast bin weil ich halt sehr viel präsent bin an dieser Stelle und das unterscheidet glaube ich von anderen Format.
Dass das was dran ist gut ja ich meine jetzt Hammer irgendwie schon über eine halbe Stunde durch hier und jetzt fühlt sich langsam an also Podcast angefangen hat ne.
Kommt jetzt die Frage ob wir noch Themen haben muss.
Bekommt meine Kapitelmarke meine gedachte jetzt immer auf dem Kongress hier das ist jetzt euer vierte.
V = V ja der erste war unter der roll.
35 ne.
31 war der erste glaube ich wohl war ne.
31er.
14 er immer so Rolltreppe dann diese Halle.
2030 wart ihr dabei.
Nee.
Nee Papa pane Mitte der mit dem Logo mit diesem an aus.
32 oder 33 wer ist für 31 wärst du 30.
Wer glaubt dem alten Mann läuft für dich Tim.
Ja ich habe schon so viele kommen und gehen sehen.
Nee dürfte ich gleich wie ich ich glaube ich glaube es war ein und drive.
Ein 30er also der.
Wir können es auch in den Songs abzählen die wir gemacht der 31.12.
So wir haben Tim verloren der rechnet jetzt noch ein bisschen nach.
Ich bin mir relativ.
Das Logo vom 30.03 nee da waren wir nicht.
Bilder weitererzählen ich 31 war der erste.
An der Rolltreppe und der Verdacht mir noch keiner kommen ne und da kann man einfach noch niemand als wir angefangen haben saßen da 30 Leute irgendwie ein Publikum und am Ende waren irgendwie 100 oder so die da so als Traube drumrum standen das war ein sehr schönes Gefühl.
Okay aber jetzt mal weg von eurer Show so jetzt seid ihr schon mit 5.
Events seid ihr qualifiziert schon über wie es früher war.
Zu reden ne na ja ich meine wie viele Leute wir können ja mal kurz Check machen also wer von euch ist es erste Mal hier.
Das sind so 30-40 zweimal also mache jetzt akkumulieren,
wir mal alle hoch die mindestens zweimal da war so genau ist schon fast die Hälfte dreimal.
Okay immer noch relativ wieder viermal noch ganz kurz fünfmal.
Aber das sind so die sind wie ihr soll das jetzt nur noch so 20 ne.
Ja dann können wir von früher erzählen.
Wer war schon zehn Mal auf dem Kongress einer.
52 315 x.
Ja komm lass die Hand oben tape.
Na gut aber das zeigt halt auch Mörder ist sozusagen.
Ja wir sind alt geworden.
Nee aber 5 Jahre ist sauer entspricht vielleicht zu der der Wahrnehmung der meisten Leute mich jetzt hier in unserem nichts repräsentative Umfrage tool.
Ja also weil ich habe da natürlich ganz andere Sicht drauf deswegen frage ich euch das also was was was habt ihr das Gefühl dass ich was,
gerne grundsätzliches verändert hat ist das so früher bei der Kongress ganz anders oder ist das jetzt immer noch dasselbe oder ist irgendwas ganz Neues noch dazu gekommen was ist was ihr so gar nicht für möglich gehalten habt oder.
Also nur eine grundsätzliche Änderung die man ja für die die wir miterlebt haben damals war ja der Kongress in Hamburg.
Ja okay gut.
Immer im CCH Unterelbe also dadurch dass die Örtlichkeiten andere ist das natürlich schon mal also es ist immer noch der Kongress ne,
aber es ist es fühlt sich ein bisschen anders an hier und da weil es es ist nicht mehr so also mir fehlt der Teppichboden.
Na da wird vermisst.
Und also ich hatte eben also beim beim 113 habe ich mich sehr oft verlaufen,
und du isst verlaufen unabsichtlich Sachen entdeckt also so kleine Nischen und so weiter dass ich mich hier noch nicht so oft passiert weil sie halt die Hallen sind da kann man so in der Halle war ich checke und,
das also ich habe das Gefühl etwas weitläufiger was nicht schlecht sein muss sondern was auch gut das war halt mehr Raum da ist für Sachen aber dass das.
Irgendwie anders ein bisschen.
Heißt du mich wahnsinnig schwer ich würde sagen also ich finde den,
diese ganze Veranstaltungen habe ich dynamisch aber dynamischen im Sinne wo sie sich immer wieder neue Situation anpasst ohne sei ohne ihren Charakter zu verlieren also bleibt immer der Kongress deswegen würde ich.
Trotzdem jedes Jahr anders ne wer.
Was kann ich also so extremen wie wie du dazu sagst also ich weiß z.b. im letzten Jahr wahnsinnig überrascht wie sehr ein neues Gebäude eingenommen wird was auch ein völlig anderen Charakter hat genau das was du gerade gesagt,
keine Eingänge großer Hallen du kannst aber trotzdem also ich meine das ist eine maximale räumliche Veränderung
und es ist trotzdem der Congresse sind trotzdem,
die Aufbauten sind natürlich andere der Raum wird besser genutzt aber du du hast den gleichen Geschmack irgendwie und das finde ich eigentlich extrem bemerkenswerte obwohl du diese disruptionen hast bleib,
el Congreso du es fühlt sich immer an wie nach Hause kommen also ich finde es interessant also wenn wenn ihr sagt ihr seht eine Entwicklung oder wird anders,
für mich die fünf Jahre.
Ich habe doch gar nichts gesagt.
Also ist ja.
Noch nicht.
Also ich finde nicht dass ich zu Veranstaltungen sich verändert hat aber die Veränderung des Ortes
hat halt irgend also nicht den Charakter geändert der fun Steinen werfen noch gleich also sie immer noch irgendwie so wir schon dass der Kongress wo man so hinkommt aber es fühlt sich für mich trotzdem irgendwie anders an ich kann nicht mal beschreiben was.
Simson wars sich natürlich schon ne letzte Jahr Hamburg war schon so leicht das Gefühl hat er alle sagten so sie sind so ein bisschen satt wir spielen hier das Spiel durch das war alles natürlich alles durchstrukturiert man wusste genau wo muss man hin wo muss müssen Dinge aufgebaut werden und dann haben Leute uns auch.
Langweilig hat die Leute gesagt lang lang.
Das Wort hätte ich mich nicht getraut.
Ja weil es keine Herausforderung mehr gab.
Warum genau ja obwohl die immer noch eine riesen Nummer ist zu stemmen ne also langweilig finde ich also ganz vorsichtig mit
Vorsicht zu genießen dieses Wort aber er ist auch bemerkenswerten er das Leute dann wirklich sagen und jetzt wollen wir wirklich dieses neue mir noch mal um noch mal weg
wirklich auf Null gesetzt zu werden und noch mal gefordert zu werden es eben auch ein Charakter der der Leute die hier hinkommen Charakter dieser Veranstaltung da habe ich schon gemerkt natürlich letzte Jahr Hamburg
1. Jahr Leipzig dieses Jahr Leipzig noch mal wo man merkt wo wir wissen wie es jetzt richtig geht in Leipzig mit meiner Türe normal dass Dinge anders funktionieren wird besser funktionieren.
Also für mich das Gefühl ich hier geht immer auf das gleiche wie in Hamburg jeder ist so ein bisschen selbst dafür verantwortlich was der Kongress ist,
also wie man den Kongress erlebt also sowohl in Hamburg als auch hier kannst du einfach rum gehen und dir Sachen an
oben ohne viel teilzuhaben wenn du willst du kannst aber genauso gut zu Leuten hingehen und fragen was machst du da und jeder erklärt dir was was du möchtest du kannst an Workshops teilnehmen
du kannst irgendwie selber Sachen bauen selber Sachen machen du kannst ja auch talks einreichen oder so also ich finde das,
Kongress hängt sehr sehr stark damit zusammen wie man also was man selber investiert oder wie man bereit ist darauf zu zu gehen.
Ich ich finde ja auch mal spannend jemand zu fragen der schon sagen wir mal so 25 Kongress erlebt hat Tim wie siehst du denn die Entwicklung.
Hat sich das eigentlich geändert.
Ja das ist schon eine Frage die mich auch mal wieder beschäftigt also Leipzig ist ja jetzt die sechste location die wir haben also,
sollte sie nicht allgemeine Erinnerung gibt's nur fünf was es gab halt
Hamburg das Eidelstedter Bürgerhaus dann gab es mal ein kurzes Intermezzo ein Versuch am Breitscheidplatz den Kongress zu machen der allgemein als gescheitert angesehen wurde.
Auf dem Platz oder.
All in diesem bikini-haus was heute so eine
Shopping Mall ist das war damals so im Büro und dann war da aber auch noch so Flächen die man für Veranstaltungen nutzen konnte brauchen wir die Berlinale sorein meandered ist und dann war das irgendwie frei und dann wurde es war.
Ich kenn das nur weil er mal Tony roma's drin war da gab es keine Rippchen.
Ob wir das war so damals es gab schon immer eine Gruppe im Club damals der Meinung war Berlin wäre doch vielleicht mal der bessere Ort und der erste Versuch ist er gescheitert dass man wieder zurück ins Bürgerhaus dann ist das Ding zu groß geworden,
dann gab es den movies Haus am köllnischen Park bis heute leider nicht mehr gibt weil es abgerissen wurde leider da ist der Kongress.
So durchgeschüttelt worden darf ich wie seitdem noch nie weil die der Faktor der Vergrößerung,
war so groß wie danach nie mehr also ich habe vorhin gerade noch mal versucht mit ein paar Altvorderen Einschätzung zu bekommen wie viele Leute wohl Ende 97 im Eidelstedter Bürgerhaus da waren als es so furchtbar voll war,
und alle so boah ist das voll hier und Orca der Kongresses überlaufen und was passiert jetzt mit dem Kongress ja wenn so viele Leute kommt ist dann der Kongress noch der Kongress,
wie alt schätzt du wie viele Leute da war es gibt keine genaue Zahl 450 bis 600.
Soll die Frage war immer die gleiche so und dann sind wir halt so dumm können Spacken gegangen beim 2300 und alle liefen so rum so.
Euch auch ganz geil so und zwar immer noch alles irgendwie genauso unterwegs sind bietet sie der war da nicht so krass.
Hat sie ja klar ich habe schon mal bisschen Zeit damit verbracht und habt so auf google maps im selben Maßstab die ganzen Locations mal ausgeschnitten und hier auf die Messehallen draufgelegt und was ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen ja also.
Muss kurz mal überlegen ob ich das richtige habe ich noch auf meinem Destop rumliegen habe ich oder habe ich nicht nervig nicht also in Eidelstedter Bürgerhaus.
Hat in etwa dieselbe Grundfläche wie die Party Zone dahinten.
Sind aber zwei Etagen von daher kann man sagen ein Viertel Halle so aber da mit viel Luft ne und Haus am köllnischen Park.
War dann schon deutlich größer aber halt als alles was wir bisher hatten passt irgendwie hier mehr oder weniger in einer Halle CCH auch so in etwa ne also weißes Gebäude sehr groß aber wenn man sich noch mal erinnert
die Leute die sich daran erinnern die engen Flur oder war das war ja relativ wenig nutzbar und,
was sich halt immer so bisschen verändert hat über die Zeit ist das Verhältnis zwischen freier Hack Bereich und Vortragsprogramm zwei haben Anfang auch sehr spartanisch meine der größte Saal im alles steht der Bürgerhaus fasste glaube ich so.
50 Leute oder so also wir sitzen jetzt hier in einem Ding locker doppelt so groß ist wie das was damals halt normal war und das erstmal sich halt so gegenseitig ein bisschen auf dem Schoß und uns wurde geraucht wie bekloppt also man kann sich das überhaupt nicht vorstellen was für Atmosphäre
abgelaufenes ne trotzdem so von der von der Stimmung her und vor allem vom Umgang miteinander war das halt doch immer noch sehr nah an dem
wie wird es heute auch erleben ja und worauf hat jetzt hinaus dass all diese Wechsel,
Hammer Auffassung nach den Charakter eigentlich immer beibehalten und will sogar so weit gehen zu sagen ist es eigentlich auch die ganze Zeit immer besser geworden,
und da habe ich selber jetzt gar nicht so eine richtig gute Erklärung dafür wie denn das überhaupt sein kannst
bist du was damit zu tun ist natürlich durch die hohe Zahl an Leuten die bereit waren mitzuhelfen auch die Kapazität was alles so geschaffen werden kann natürlich auch angestiegen ist ne am Anfang wurde das vielleicht von zehn Leuten getragen
klar da kannst du nicht irgendwie solche Welten aufbauen wie hier ne mittlerweile haben wir hier mehr meerengel als wir,
doppelt so viele Engel wie wir damals und wie im ganzen Gebäude und das ist schön.
Ocelot
so will ich's wirklich bemerkenswert wärmt vor 2 Tagen schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen du hast natürlich durch diese schiere Größe ne auch mehr Leute die nicht aus dem eng.
Hacker Umfeld kommen würde ich mal sagen also du hast viele viele Leute die von von außen kommen ich meine wir beide haben uns jetzt auch nicht als Hacker bezeichnen sondern die sind ja auch irgendwie von außen gekommen und trotzdem ist der Charakter dieser Veranstaltung irgendwie
ähnlich geblieben oder gleich geblieben wer bin ich schon sehr sehr bemerkenswert muss ich sagen weil ich ärger dich fragen
wirklich woran das liegt weil gerade heutzutage haben ja extrem viele Leute Sorge wenn von außen Mensch andersdenkende Menschen kommen dass die gesamte Identität der Bevölkerung in Gefahr ist wird passiert eben hier nicht.
Ich hatte dazu genau dazu heute eine sehr schöne Unterhaltung zu habe ich mich mit jemanden also mit einem Elektrotechniker unterhalten der zu mir meinte ja ich habe mich noch nicht getraut hier mit dem assembly mal irgendwas auszubauen und so weil so so riecht
also ich kriege ja eigentlich ich komme ja auch so von außen und so ich gehöre ja gar nicht so richtig hin und dem habe ich dann gesagt genau das gesagt was du uns letztes Jahr gesagt hast als wir auch gesagt haben soll er ist mir sowieso Wissenschaftler eigentlich so,
irgendwie wie bekommen wir auch so von außen und du hast einfach mal zu ich habe von Mira oder sowas auch gesagt zu ihr steckt viel viel tiefer drin als sie eigentlich glaubt und genauso habe ich dir diesen also diesen jungen Herren das heute Auto wird so,
du bist hier du hast die Tochter du redest Mitmenschen du du brennst für dein Thema bei dem ging es um
um um um Industriesteuerungen fragt ob das hier irgendjemand vielleicht interessieren könnte ne weil der ganze Zeit irgendwie Industriesteuerungen so einbaut und meinst du ja da gibt's zu diverse Gateways diesen immer offen und
aber das weiß man ja ist ja du weißt das aber ich darf hier gibt's ne Menge Leute jetzt nicht dass du jetzt auch interessant finden ne.
Reicht doch mal zocken oder Sterne Büchse irgendwohin die du mitbringen kannst klebt die IP dran und guck was passiert,
ja kann doch interessant sein oder also ich glaube dass das interessant wäre also das,
das also dass du wohl eher was dabei lernt als auch die Hersteller von den Dingern was dabei lernen als auch die Leute die hier sind was dabei lehrt und alle Sachen Spaß haben und
bei dem es genauso also der der sagt hast du ja irgendwie weiß ich nicht ob ich eigentlich dazu gehöre aber der steht auch schon viel viel tiefer drin als er eigentlich selber glaubt.
Hacking is not about computer it is state of mind er also das ist,
diese ganze Wahrnehmung das Hacken irgendwas mit Computern zu tun hat die ist der der eigentliche Denkfehler in der ganzen Geschichte und.
Meine schau mal auf so Leute wie ach jetzt wenig zu sehr in der Vergangenheit rum Suppen aber es war schon immer so der Club war von Anfang an,
eine eine unfassbare Bandbreite quer durch die Gesellschaft du hattest da Rechtsanwälte Künstler
Schriftsteller also auch viele der prägenden Leute hier so Peter Glaser ja auch genug da,
super Schriftsteller Buchautor Schreiberling top Twitterer ja war hat er die Datenschleuder gemacht und
all diese ganzen Geschichten und der Club ist immer sehr breit eigentlich in dieser Gesellschaft gewesen aber was die Leute halt vereint ist halt ne
Sicht auf die Welt so und das ist ja bei euch deswegen habe ich da auch gleich immer mit dem Kopf geschüttelt ne wenn du sagst hat mehr wissen ja eigentlich gar keine Hacker sorry
ihr blickt auf die Welt und versucht sie zu verstehen und Brecht sie mit logischen Mitteln auf also wenn das jetzt nicht Hacker Mentalität ist dann können wir die Veranstaltung auch gleich absagen ja
und deswegen daraus erkläre ich mir halt auch dass dieses dieses ja offensichtlich nicht enden wollende Potential an Neuzugängen.
Das immer wieder Leute hierher kommen und dann eben auch so ein bisschen entweder bewusst oder unbewusst das zu merken mit so einer her so ganz falsch bin ich ja jetzt eigentlich gar nicht ne weil das ja hier ist eigentlich mittlerweile sehr viel mehr ist als nur
eine Veranstaltung wo so ein bisschen IT security Weg geklöppelt wird sein dass ich hier treffen sich halt die Leute die mit dem bekloppt
Zustand da draußen einfach nicht froh werden hier herkommen
bestellen so oh geil arschlochfreie Zone ist ja wär auch mal jetzt nicht so eine schlechte Idee und dann eben auch so diesen Schmerz verspüren am Ende wenn sie wieder nach Hause gehen oder in die Arbeit oder was auch immer für Kontext.
Ja jetzt vielleicht sowas was was über die Jahre bei mir tatsächlich immer stärker geworden ist sie war schon immer so eine Komfortzone wenn man hier ist aber jetzt dadurch dass der Kontrast nach draußen immer größer wird weil draußen halt immer mehr
a********** sind sie sind halt schon hier so diese Utopie oder also ist ja keine Utopie seine reale,
reale Veranstaltung diese unglaubliche Offenheit die dann aber dazu füttert ihr was ganz ganz tolles entsteht tut tut von Jahr zu Jahr mir.
Gute besser fühlt sich mehr von Jahr zu Jahr besser.
Bestesten.
Am pilsies man das.
Komm bei UKW dem Grammatik.
Dann gibt's natürlich immer Kritiker ne ja immer erkennt das früher dann doch alles besser war auch auf dem Kongress.
Und ich Stutz dann immer so ein bisschen weil wir haben so immer so meine ich mein Lieblingsthema ne so Navi ist.
Und mal so rauszukitzeln wie denn so die Wahrnehmung hier so ist und
da kriegst du auch alle Spektakel ne Christa halt auch so dieses so na ja jetzt ist viel bunt und jetzt ist überall Tamtam aber alle die sitzen ja alle nur in ihrer als Handy rum und irgendwie die reden ja gar nicht mehr miteinander und so ich
gibt das jetzt nur wieder das kam vorhin noch mal war vielleicht ernst gemeint aber ich glaube auch nicht abschließend beobachtet.
Ist das also wie nehmt ihr das war also wie seht ihr so dieses Ideal dass wir reden jetzt mal alle miteinander also ich,
lustigerweise mit wenn man mit den alten Hasen Rede,
riecht man das halt öfter so und die neuen sind eigentlich eigentlich immer erstmal total angetan und das passt halt dann auch irgendwie nicht zusammen weil wenn es ja so wäre dann müsste es ja eigentlich auch,
Leuten das erste oder zweite Mal da sind auch auf.
Ich echt dachte dass das hat auch wieder was damit zu tun mit was von erwarten du da dran gehst also wenn du jetzt wenn jetzt irgendwie.
Was nicht hier ich hier hinkommst und die Erwartungshaltung hast dass du Fachgespräche für sonst weiter musste die Leute vielleicht mehr suchen weil einfach mehr Leute da sind,
unter die Leute die jetzt irgendwie also nicht Fachgespräch über LTE Security mit dir führen können halt nicht also in 17000 Leute nicht so leicht zu finden sind wir in über 200 Leuten vielleicht hast du dann das Gefühl
das verwässert ist in an für.
Ich muss mal eben was wer muss aber verfallen als ging in dem Kontext konkret so um,
Aktivismus und politischen Aktivismus und so weiter also komm wir hier nur zusammen und und und feiern uns gegenseitig ab wie geil wir doch hinten was für eine schöne Zeit hatten ja oder hat der Kongress auch am Ende des Potenzial dass alle ja rausgehen und sagen
mois muss ich aber unbedingt mal in Richtung X auch was tun.
So jetzt muss ich hier was ändern das muss ich irgendwo beitreten was gründen was anschieben was unterstützen was was mitmachen
um halt irgendwie unserer Wahrnehmung der Verrohung des allgemeinen Umgangs irgendwas entgegenzusetzen.
Krages ist das irgendwie meßbar also.
Schwierig auf jeden Fall.
Also hattest du also ich meine du bist ja schon lange dabei ne hast du mal mit also außerhalb deiner direkt
Bekanntschaft mit Leuten geredet die die irgendwie erzählt haben also wo wo genau sowas passiert ist du hier ich war letztes Jahr da auf das gehört und habe gedacht ich muss mal was tun und habe was getan also hast Du Berichte von Leuten gehört die wirkt,
aktiv geworden sind im politischen irgendeiner Form oder.
Ja alles mögliche also ich fand z.b. auch hier so und dass dass das
zeigt sich ja ja auch also wie sehr teilweise 20:15 Uhr ganzen Flüchtlings würden da auch konkret Aktionen ergriffen wurde ich kann jetzt immer nicht im Einzelnen sagen wer jetzt sozusagen
ohnehin schon in so einen Kontext unterwegs war und wer das so zeigen nur rein getragen hat als Thema,
oder eben vielleicht weil das Thema rein getragen wurde sich dem angeschlossen hat aber ich,
ich bin ein Optimist und von daher mit solchen düsteren
Deutung schwer zu bewegen weil ich denke das lässt sich erstmal sowieso nicht sofort messen
ja das ist etwas was was er langfristig ist und es hängt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt davon ab ob irgendwie wie viele Blinker Lämpchen jetzt irgendwo aufgehängt sind oder wie sehr man da so einen virtuellen Gartenzaun um seine es Handy rum gebaut hat weil
solche Gruppenbildungen natürlich auch ein positiver Effekt sind ja komm Leute hierher
sensoa hier Leute aus meinem meiner Stadt meiner Region ec8 und ihr macht da was und so weiter das gibt's ja auch alles und dann entsteht halt diese Wirkung dann
erst viel später dann kann man noch mal auf die Welt unsere kleine Welt,
wie zufrieden seid ihr denn so mit dem Ist-Zustand gerade.
Du schreibst so irgendwas jetzt noch auf.
Ich bin ich bin hier Unterricht zufrieden und das also vom Gesamtzustand der Welt.
Also ich finde jetzt vom Gesamtzustand ja nicht von deinem persönlichen von deiner kleinen also von unserer kleinen wird nicht deiner kleinen wildwestheld DKW.
Der der der gesamte also der gesamten fällt das ist schon schwierig ne sag mal so.
Also ganz ehrlich da kam gesagt kann man nicht zufrieden mit zahlen wenn du wenn es wenn er sie es wird für Gedanken welche welche Sätze im im Bundestag auf einmal wieder fallen das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass ich das in meiner zu meiner Lebzeit noch mal erlebt also.
Also die ganzen Nazi Scheiß muss mir ja gar nicht mehr also ja doch man sollte darüber reden aber das mal ne also dass das halt kacke ist.
Das ist ja kein also da muss man sich keine da muss man jetzt nicht anfangen Meinung zu diskutieren das ist halt scheiße ne,
ey aber es ist darf es halt drinne unsere Situation hier gerade in Deutschland dass wir uns wieder mit irgendwie mit verschissen rumschlagen müssen und mit ihm welchen Vollidioten aber so gesamt weltpolitisch weiß ich nicht was mal schlimmer als.
Ja war es.
Weil ich eigentlich immer.
Ja genau ja eigentlich schon ne ich meine so Kalter Krieg die Welt stand schon mehr als einmal so sehr sehr nahm ab,
und eigentlich geht's uns ganz gut und wenn man also wie du wieder dieses typische wenn man man sich nicht die Berichterstattung anguckt sollen erstmal Statistiken ne Kriminalität ist generell rückläufig und so weiter und weiter eigentlich geht's uns immer also uns geht's halt gut,
nee wir haben mich also hier schon mal gar nichts zu meckern wieso gesamt also weiß nicht wie wie sieht's für die Menschheit gesamt aus man so hoch aufhängen möchte,
weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Finde ich schwierig zu sagen also zu urteilen Vivis der gesamten der gesamt Menschheit geht also wenn man sich. Punktuell Sachen anguckt findet man natürlich immer Sachen die Kacke sind eher sowas wie Klimawandel Kacke Trump
Kacke AFD kacke
du du du findest genauso gute viele viele tolle Sachen na die irgendwie die toll sind also du findest zu ihr zu jeder Sache die in die Scheiße hinter irgendwas was sie da gut ist ein du findest Halbwaise nicht du hasst Flüchtlinge die die im Mittelmeer versuchen ihn mir nach Europa zu kommen einerseits eine Menge Menschen ertrinken andererseits siehst du auch Menschen
die diese Menschen retten und das selbst losmachen und wenn sie dafür selber in den Knast gehen,
kannst trotzdem noch Anstand die Menschen aus dem Meer zu fischen was ich super finde also eine gewisse Form von Haltungen ne also man findet zu jedem negativen Punkt auch immer einen positiven. Irgendwie und.
Ich finde schwer zu sagen ob wir ob wir jetzt in der gesamte also die gesamte Situation der Welt ob das jetzt irgendwie schlimm oder gut ist falls doch irgendwie dann doch auch eine sehr persönliche Sache ist ne was man so selbst mit.
Okay also heute.
Okay das weiß ein bisschen fies gefragt ich weiß aber ich dachte ich fand erstmal groß auf aber.
Wird immer Sommer auch sagen wir mal auf euren Fachbereich.
Sick.
Super alles.
Na wissen wissen.
Also.
Wer geht ja ich weiß ja konkret Wissenschaften die Wahrnehmung von Wissenschaft ist ja bei euch auch ein Dauerthema ihr seid jetzt noch nicht so im flat-earth debunking biznis angekommen.
Falera.
Ich will irgendwas die letzten Monate zwei Monate wirklich viel Zeit damit verbracht wie auf YouTube flat Earth debunking Videos anzuschauen.
Also diese ganzen Flat ausgraben sollen sogleich in der kommentierten Fassung Mittwoch warum warum er alle falsch liegt wenn man weil ich mich halt einfach immer die ganze Zeit gefragt habe.
Was in aller Welt treibt Leute dazu eine eine eine Wahrnehmung,
von allem davon der Welt zu haben die irgendwie so offensichtlich völlig neben der Spur ist Sauna und damit natürlich verbunden und das,
geht dann auch weit über diese ganze flat-earth Geschichte hinaus das Problem dass wir jetzt eben durch die Geister die wir riefen nämlich das Internet,
auf einmal so Diskurs Problem hab was ne auf einmal,
stimmen die früher immer leise geblieben wären weil sie es wahrscheinlich auch verdient hätte
auf einmal amplifizieren und wir eben in dieser problematischen Wahrnehmung
weil alte Medienkonzepte treffen auf neue Medien Techniken und alles passt nicht mehr so richtig zusammen sich das Ganze so und wunderbar auch schaut.
Früher früher wärst du eine Spinne im Dorf
gewesen hat Problem ist dieser eine Spinne findet jetzt halt 100 andere Spinner in anderen Dörfern und die können sich zusammenschließen und haben auf einmal eine Stimme das Problem ist die haben häufig die laute Stimme weil die halt ins ins Netz brüllen dann auch so wie du es gerade gesagt hast und auf einmal hast du halt mit Leuten zu tun die
informiertes Wasser herstellen oder irgendwelche Linien am Himmel sehen oder eben die flache Erde wieder.
Oder den Klimawandel leugnen David Tanja wirklich meinst also diese Linien am Himmel da sag ok dann lass sie reden aber wenn wenn so Klimawandel das geht dann ja ins politische oder müssen Entscheidung getroffen werden wenn das irgendwann mal so eine so eine Stimmung wird dann wird er,
düster für uns alle wenn wenn auf Basis von von Falschinformationen dann
Entscheidung getroffen werden und ja da das ist extrem besorgniserregend das spannt dass du das sagst weil das war unter anderem auch eine eine Idee du hast ihn noch nicht gesehen aber wo wir gesagt haben dass es etwas was wir gerne in unserer Live-Show thematisieren wollen weil
oder Podcast ist ja immer so ein bisschen so oder wir so das aktuelle Tagesgeschehen abhandeln aber bei der live Liveshow oder wollten wir schon schon größeres Thema an,
und das genau diese diese Geschichte die du die du jetzt angesprochen hast
weil wir die Beobachtung gemacht haben dass diese diese wissenschaftliche Weltanschauung also wie blicken wir auf die Welt wie versuchen wir unsere Welt zu verstehen.
Mit wissenschaftlichen Methoden dass diese sich irgendwie so ein bisschen erodiert und dann auf einmal Meinung und Gefühle da wieder ne Rolle.
Die die Leute fangen plötzlich an Meinung zu disc
Tieren und wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis mit Meinung gleichzusetzen also sowas zu sagen wir aber das ja auch eine mögliche Erklärung mehr also ich glaube das ist so und so du glaubst mit deiner Wissenschaft dass es so und so ne Wissenschaft es keine fairfit
der Meinung mehr das ist das etwas anderes das ist das ist etwas überprüfbar es ist etwas dass du im Konsens mit einem also Wissenschaft ist eine Metro das ist eine Art zu denken ist eine SAT
eine Art Sachen überprüfbar zu machen also Experimente zu machen
und das immer wieder zu überprüfen und auch zu verwerfen wenn es halt demnächst Moment widerspricht und so und das ist keine Meinung das ist es was anderes und
das ja das ist wichtig den Leuten irgendwie beizubringen und vor allem
bin also gerade jetzt also gerade wo wir so sowas wie Internet Klimawandel ansprechen ich habe so um Weihnachten rum
mit mit jemanden den ich für einen einzigen Menschen halte und auch eigentlich sehr schätze also jemand Rentner sehr viel Zeit im Internet zu lesen nicht zwingend gut
und der der kam auf mich zu und sagte was das aussieht ja mit dem Klimawandel ich weiß ja nicht,
katahiro folgende Quellen ne und dann kann der mit ihm die Russia Today Deutschland.
Dass du das Problem also dass er überall so macht man selbst denkt so ah ja okay ne Russia Today Deutschland das Problem für viele viele Menschen ist das.
Dass man Informationen ja irgendwie einordnen muss sind diese Information vertrauenswürdig oder nicht ne also wenn mir persona ihm gesagt hier ich habe vorhin Erkenntnis mit 20 mit 20 studieren und Person B sagt das gleiche auch mit 20 studiert muss ich ja irgendwie beurteilen
okay beide haben irgendwie angeblich Peer-Review studieren welche davon sind jetzt glaubwürdig wenn ich da ein bisschen genauer hin gucke sehe ich bei dem ein okay das ist Heinz nature und was weiß ich nicht was und der Typ der das erzählt,
hat irgendwie ein Doktor ein Klimawissenschaft und bei dem anderen sich der ist Elektrotechniker und das sind 20% Originals und der was weiß ich nicht vertreibt in seiner Freizeit noch energetisiertes Wasser dann weiß ich,
ist nicht ganz so vertrauenswürdig vielleicht,
aber so weit zu gucken erstmal von wem kommt die Informationen was für ein background hat der oder die wie ist diese Information untermauert
das ist ein Punkt den man vielen Leuten erst beibringen muss oder dem man den Leuten noch mal sagen dass dass es wichtig ist Information alleine reicht halt nicht sondern muss sie auch irgendwie in einen Gesamtzusammenhang bringen und auf sich den Rahmen angucken wie du sonst mal zum zustande gekommen sind das
das viel viel Leuten das viel zu dieser Person also mit mit echter geredet habe auch für die war das gleichwertig
also diese Information von diesem klimaleugner und von von Studien die in ordentlichen journaled veröffentlicht wohnen war für den
im ersten Moment gleichwertig wenn man den Leuten erklären muss das gibt einen Unterschied.
Sagte er Apologet des open-access und des freien schnellen Zugriffs auf Studien im Internet und preist dann die großen Journale.
Erinnerungen.
Sag ihr ihr Neumond.
Ja im Moment das ist ja ein Unterschied also open-access ist super wichtig aber open-access muss trotzdem wissenschaftlichen Standards genügen,
also ich möchte ich möchte Open Access in jeder Form ich möchte also ich find euch toll wenn wenn es ein Teenager open-access werden es widerspricht sich ja nicht dass man qualitativ hochwertige John und hat die Open Access.
War nur eine kleine Spitze aber ich habe gerade überlegt ob wenn du Sack.
Feiert.
Wir haben ja wir haben ja eine wissenschaftliche Methode vielleicht fehlt uns ja etwas was man in Zukunft die gesellschaftliche Methode nennen könnte,
also quasi ein eine Methode wir sozusagen auch in der Gesellschaft über solche Problemfälle hin arbeiten können was er derzeit sozusagen totaler Wildwuchs und Wahnsinn.
Also ich habe nur bei der Wissenschaft die Methode oder bei Wissenschaft an sich immer das Gefühl also ich sehe Wissenschaft als unabhängigen Rahmen und Basis
stimmt wir in irgendeiner Form als Gesellschaft Entscheidungen fällen können und wollen und mir fällt ehrlich gesagt ich habe viel und lange drüber nachgedacht
keine Alternative eins zu einer Wissenschaft also zu einem wissenschaftlich fundierten Weltbild oder einer wissenschaftlich fundierten Basis fällt mir keine Alternativen auch ein gesellschaftliches Weltbild sehr gerne aber das braucht als grundlegendes,
umfassendes Weltbild braucht das eine braucht das Wissenschaft weil
ich aber ich möchte nicht in einer Welt leben in der in der wir Entscheidungen auf Basis von Meinungen Gefühlen und also Gefühle sind natürlich auch wichtig aber ich möchte in einer in einer Welt leben in der in der etwas logisch,
ist also im Internet was eine berechenbare Basis hat auf der Auto auf die wir uns irgendwie einigen können irgendwas was unabhängig ist was nicht beeinflusst wird von Meinungen oder von von ihm die Befindlichkeit.
Ist das realistisch also ich meine kannst du dir so ein eine wissenschaftliche Gesellschaft vorstellen diese komplett auf Gott und diesen ganzen Kram verzichtet.
Ich finde es schön.
Nee aber hältst du es für realistisch.
Ich finde auch nicht um damer zwischen sogar ich will ich finde nicht dass es sich ausschließt also überhaupt nicht also ich finde es Religion für dich völlig okay wenn es wenn es Leuten was bringt.
Natürlich also ich kann es ja auch gerne geben ne aber ich möchte nicht ich möchte nicht Entscheidungen die die Allgemeinheit betreffen auf Basis von religiösen Gefühlen.
Will ja auch keiner Ich will dich würd sogar noch in ganz anderen Schritt gehen ich ich ich finde es problematisch wenn Leute,
auf unser Spielfeld kommen nämlich der Wissenschaft und sich mit den Begrifflichkeiten der Wissenschaft schmücken um ihre,
Methoden um ihre Produkte zu
zu bewerben also ich meine Rainer du erzählst immer gerne die Geschichte wie du beim Arzt warst und er hat dann gesagt es ist Homöopathie also dein Liebste war beim Arzt.
Dass er so die Graffiti safe.tv die war also meine Liebste war ein bisschen erkältet leicht verschnupft und abends noch kurz beim Arzt vorbei,
unsere I was die Ärztin fragte war was halten Sie denn von homöop
Kathi ich hätte da was und meine Liebste sagte wortgetreu so etwas wie nein danke wir haben ein naturwissenschaftliches Weltbild oder was sagte die Ärztin sowas wie Astrid sich doch super das ist Quantenmechanik.
Geil ne ich war.
Ich war leider nicht anwesend ich habe das erste ich habe das von meiner von meiner lieben erst erfahren als wir draußen waren aus der Presse ich hätte so gerne nachgefragt.
Was.
Ich hätte ich hätte ich hätte dich gefragt könnten.
Das trifft sich gut ich habe ein Diplom in Quantenmechanik.
Ich hätte ich hätte tatsächlich gefragt ob die mir das mal genauer erklären kann ob Sie mir bitte mal erklären kann inwiefern Quantenmechanik etwas mit Homöopathie zu tun hat also was genau,
da also wie ich hätte halt so lang also ich hätte ich hätte versucht so lange zu fragen bis der Frau auffällt dass sie das selber halt ne Ahnung. Ist wo sie gar nicht verstanden hat wovon sie redet.
Das ist auch hingehen ich meine kannst du mit demselben leiden darauf.
Ja ich habe schon seit ich müsste ein Tag später noch mal vorbei.
Aber das ist genau das Problem was ich sehe naja also.
Taxi möchte mit Ihnen über.
Sitze Privatpatient.
Ja oh scheiße das hatte ich Probleme also wenn die Leute auf unser Spielfeld kommen und sich mit diesen wissenschaftlichen Begrifflichkeiten schmücken um um ihre Methoden
sit up abzusichern da habe ich da wirklich ein Problem mit und dann müssen sie einfach auch mit den wissenschaftlichen Methoden messen also Peer-Review beispielsweise genauso wie bei der Homöopathie ich habe überhaupt kein Problem damit dass man sagte es gibt es gibt
Gefühle oder es gibt
Gabe wenn man sich Leute Wohlfühlen im Krankenhaus der wittert im Heilungsprozess gut tun habe ich überhaupt kein Problem mit kann man auch wissenschaftlich belegen,
aber Homöopathie hat nunmal keine keine keine Bier,
über über über die über die Placebowirkung hinaus und damit habe ich dann halt ein bisschen Probleme wenn das als Medizin verkauft wird und genau da sehe ich ein Problem nicht dass wir irgendwie drüber reden müssen ob wir eine end.
And gfriend emotionalisierte Gesellschaft brauchen und eine rein wissenschaftliche absolut nicht Emotionen sind wichtig auch für den für den Heilungsprozess auch für für Produkte sind Emotionen wichtig aber wenn es um Wissenschaft geht.
Und dann sind wir beim Impfen dann sind wir bei der Homöopathie dann sind wir bei der flachen Erde dann möchte ich belege sehen.
Verwirbeltes Wasser.
Verwirbeltes Wasser natürliche.
Schwierig wird glaube ich immer dann wenn es wirklich nah an einen herankommt also wenn man irgendwie nur irgendwelche Trolle im Internet wegfegen muss dann geht das ja irgendwie relativ leicht mehr Argument drauf Deckel zu Affe tot
ich hatte neulich auch mal wieder so den Fall dass ich so bei,
Party Freunden eingeladen war und dann kommt dann halt so eine Gruppe zusammen die man vielleicht schon seit zehn Jahren vielleicht nicht nicht aber so sehr eingeschränkt wahrgenommen hat,
und dann ist dann halt auch so der wasserverwirbler da und es wird munter darüber diskutiert ob den das was bringt und Yara Nacht und,
viel besser und so kein Vergleich zu vorher ne wo ich dann halt auch so stehe so
okay also ich könnte jetzt hier irgendwie machen die Abdankung Freundschaft aufs Spiel setzen weil wenn ich erstmal anfange richtig los zu raten irgendwie deine Berlin die auch zweimal noch ob sie mich einige kennen
und.
Ja da sehe ich halt genau das Problem die Leute sind im Prinzip dann schon verlorene ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ob ich dann auf der Party unbedingt an,
ja doch mal dort man sollte aufstehen und Scheiße schreien dann sage ich habe ich ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen eigentlich habe ich bis bis letztes Jahr habe ich immer so gedacht ja kommen dann dann glauben sie da dran ist egal,
lass lass lieber früh anfangen lass bei der Jugend anfangen lass lass lass es Wissenschaft predigen dann die lieber noch nicht verloren haben aber eigentlich ist es seit kurzen und denke ich das ist der falsche Ansatz Reinert hat war es ja mal eben mit der Bahn gefahren und hat so eine Tüte beim Bäcker gekauft wo dann drauf Spruch drauf steht mit Granderwasser
das Brot da muss man eigentlich aufstehen und sagen scheiße so weil wir sind mit die schweigende Mehrheit die da drauf guckt und sagt,
komm ist egal.
Ja bei wem wem wem sagst.
Und die und die anderen sagen wir wir wir wollen gern.
Sowas von Granderwasser mal Bauchschmerzen so nein.
Na dann.
Genau dass das nicht sagst du du gehst du gehst einfach hin und sagst ihm.
Ich will nicht so ein Scheiß.
Du willst es nicht anders.
Du sagst einfach und Untersuchung sondern auch die Diebe die positive Botschaft wir hatten Katze hier auch Leute die uns eine E-Mail geschrieben haben die gesagt haben sie haben rotbäckchensaft für das gibt man Kinder glaube ich ne rote.
Ja so Multivitaminsaft in auenapotheke Griff.
Hat er haben sie den Hansi mal gekauft bis zu dem Zeitpunkt wo der Barcode entstört wurde das ist auch wieder so eine geile Geschichte Barcodes hier sind diese Striche ne böse sind Antennen machen das Bio negatives Spray.
Negative Schwingungen die neben negative Schwingungen.
Die dass das Bio Getränk wird wird dadurch böse, glaube ich sagen.
Ja es wird halt schlecht ne schlechte Energien und.
Lösung ist einfach Strich durchmachen oder diese diese Striche irgendwie unterbrechen und dann hat sie wohl Rotbäckchen eben angefangen das mal zu machen und dann haben relativ viele Leute an rot
Bäckchen geschrieben wir kaufen euer Zeug nicht mehr mal weg,
Kopfarbeit ihr auch sowieso Schwachsinn auf aufsteigt und dann hat Rotbäckchen hat seine E-Mail geschrieben an diesen Hörer der da auch eine E-Mail hingeschrieben hat und und haben gesagt okay wir wollen uns da nicht einmischen wir sind offen für alle
Sichtweisen auf diese auf diese Welt aber es gibt offensichtlich die Leute die glauben hatte das ist böse für unser Produkt
es gibt Leute die sagen wir kaufen dann nicht mehr wenn ich auf so ein Esel scheiß auf aufsteigt und deswegen haben uns entschieden wir lassen den Barcode so wie er ist also so,
Innenstadt sage ich jetzt mal Antennen und das finde ich ist doch schonmal ganz gutes Zeichen wir müssen unsere Stimme erheben das ganz ganz wichtig wir dürfen nicht die die,
Didi informierten Menschen sein die sagen ist egal lass die Spinner nee wir müssen sagen wir haben keinen Bock
mehr drauf also wir haben keinen Bock mehr drauf dass der Diskurs geführt wird von denen dann gerade gesagt 100 Leuten den eben die Wäsche Dörfern oder Städten sitzen und und halt die ihren Schwachsinn ausbrüten und damit halt immer mehr Stimmen finden
du bist mal aufstehen.
Genau das ist selbst bei Kleinigkeiten wichtig also sei jetzt ein entstörter Barcode seist der Bäcker der mit Granderwasser seine Brötchen backen was erstaunlich viele sind also wirklich erschreckend viele
man könnte jetzt denken ja komm lass uns Kleinigkeit aber diese Kleinigkeiten bieten ja bieten sowas für ein Keim so einen eine Saat für für größeren Schwachsinn aber du fängst damit an
sag dann immer die herkommen ist ok aber dann dann wann es irgendwann bei Homöopathie na dann landest du irgendwann bei Klimaanlagen an dann bist du irgendwann
bitte halt beim beim größten Scheiß angelangt das wär so wichtig wirklich bei bei den kleinsten Dingen anzufangen also.
Ja man muss da schon ein bisschen pressure mach mein lieblings Berlin wird es ja ja du wir können uns gerne im Prenzlauer Berg treffen ich bin geimpft.
Ja wär lustig werde nicht so traurig.
Ja ja wenn ja und das und das und gerade der Prenzlauer Berg fällt mir gerade wieder ein ist ein besonderes disaster,
weil also das hat sie auch schon so rumgesprochen ist mittlerweile geht gerade wieder ne aber es gab halt Masernfälle,
im Prenzlauer Berg was ist der Prenzlauer Berg Prenzlauer Berg ist der durchgehend infiziertes Bereich in Berlin überhaupt,
Mittelschicht international,
aufgeklärte wohl gebildete Leute extrem viel im universitären Bereich also du würdest ja nun wirklich mal meinen wenn irgendwo das Hirn ab regnet dann doch irgendwie über diesen Bezirk Ja und
genau da geht's dann auf einmal mit Masern.
Fragt man sich warum ne.
Habe ich auch noch nicht da habe ich ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht so ganz zusammen gekriegt ich glaube also Gelsenkirchen-Schalke ist glaube ich durchgehend also nur so.
Man kann nicht viel.
Überlebst du da auch nicht.
Gelsenkirchen sagen aber das kann ich glaube ich.
Von von wegen woanders ist auch scheiße ne.
Jakatta warum wurden Wallis.
Vielleicht gleich bei Bildung nichts mit naturwissenschaftliche Bildung.
Oh das wird schwierig jetzt.
Ja ich weiß ich weiß aber ja weiß ich nicht also weißt du nicht ein Thema ist mit dem du dich nicht beschäftigt hast also weiß ich nicht du du du kannst du kannst ja auch gebildet sein
ohne in ihren also ohne wissenschaftliche also ohne empirisch wissenschaftlich zu arbeiten,
du kannst ja auch wissenschaftlich also hat meiner Bretter für meinen sagte nicht.
Willst du du du kannst du kannst auch wissenschaftlich arbeiten ohne empirisch zu arbeiten also du kannst ja auch irgendwie literarisch wissenschaftlich arbeiten ohne irgendwie mal was von Statistik gehört zu haben.
Er ist glaube ich auch viel mit dem zu tun
so Wissenschaft hin Wissenschaft her am Ende wissen die Leute derzeit einfach gerade gar nicht mehr wem sie noch glauben sollen so im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und es hat,
unter anderen damit zu tun dass es ja nicht nur so irgendwie etwas was ist
was gerade passiert sollen wir erleben ja unter anderem auch eine massiver,
vorsätzliche Beeinflussung der öffentlichen Debatte werde ich mal Frank Rieger auch bei
Peter sich ausführlich mit dem Thema beschäftigt er meinte halt so na ja dass das Ziel dieser Störer ist die Zerrüttung des öffentlichen Diskurses,
alles irgendwie möglich ist dass es nicht mehr wahr
und dann kannst du halt in dieser Abwesenheit von Wahrheiten eben auch einfach überhaupt gar keine gesetzte Logik mehr anbringen weil Leute immer Antworten mit naja aber ich habe halt auch was anderes darüber gelesen,
na das ne aber wir sind ja total super zertifiziert jägert jetzt gerade gestern und heute morgen auf dem Kongress massives gesehen habe auch so ein
Talk über diese Prittitz Originals du schon gerade erwähnt.
Bist ich musste zu der Zeiten Podcast aufnehmen ich hoffe du.
Ja nee ist ja in Ordnung.
Zufällig heute morgen beim Kaffee dann noch im Stream schauen können und war ganz interessant weil sie halt mal wirklich Daten erzeugt haben so Wer publiziert bei diesem Donalds was passiert wenn man dann die Unternehmen an
wie kann man eine Änderung erzählen Spoiler ja so also,
ich glaube so finden auch sehr dass er der Türkei euch empfehlen schaut euch den an weil das ist halt so zeigen auch wie ein schönes Beispiel wie man ihm auch gegen arbeiten kann also ich denke daraus kann man auch lernen dass es eben durchaus hilft habe ich dann noch ganz bei dir nicht was man muss halt irgendwie,
nicht aufgeben und zusehen dass man eben die andere Botschaft auch rüber bringt mach dir ja auch ganz gut finde ich übrigens.
Ja ich bin auch Fan.
Prädikat.
Ja noch etwas was ihr vielleicht auch aufbringen oder fragen möchte.
Rittermahl auch fragen außen.
Oh ja das ist mal.
Aus dem Publikum das können wir auch noch einbinden weil ich muss ja nicht immer alles Fragen ne genau.
Oder ganz hinten ist so frei.
Und da ist ein Mikrofon da vorne.
Genau aber nicht Trollen das sogar der.
Ist das nicht mehr von indirekte Aufforderung zum trollen oder.
Ja ich hab Vertrauen ist aber die Frage wer wie sieht ein wie sieht die Wissenschaft Methode von Literatur aus.
Zu Rainer tursky dein.
Das ist ein bisschen genauer formulieren.
Mit Honig auf den Tod ist ja bekannt also These aufstellen gegen Käse und so weiter.
Die drei wurde gerade eben argumentiert bei literaturquiz soll auch oder anderen Wissenschaften Deziliter totenmeister sich mich aufwecken bezeichnet viseris daraus also.
Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich eine Literaturwissenschaftler fragen,
was also ich weiß nicht für also ich bin halt ich bin Physiker und für mich ist wissenschaftliche Methode sehr eng mit Mathematik verknüpft und mit mit Experimenten und so weiter ich,
also ich war ich weiß nicht wie wie Wissenschaft im Sinne also wie inwiefern sind Radtour Wissenschaft aussieht.
Ich glaube dass man ich glaube dass man Texte auch wissenschaftlich untersuchen kann indem man sie geschichtlich einordnet also in den
Sozialkontakt stellt in dem also in den geschichtlichen Kontext vor allem indem sie geschrieben wurden wie die Gesellschaft zu der Zeit aussah und,
ich denke schon dass man das wissenschaftlich untersuchen kann aber das eine andere Art von Wissenschaft als sie jetzt beispielsweise Physik ist mit Experimenten und ähnlich,
also ich denke eine Wissenschaft mit totem bereits immer schon Literatur sehe in also ich ich habe keine Ahnung weil ich kein Literaturwissenschaftler bin aber ich denke das wäre so etwas wie halt diesen Text einzuordnen und im gesellschaftlichen Kontext zu stellen,
seinerzeit vor allem.
Gibt's aber du bist keine absoluten Wahrheit.
Ja das also das ist das in der Physik manchmal war auch schwierig mit den absoluten waren ja sag mal so auf die Wissenschaft Methode also auch die Physik,
nie den Anspruch absolute Wahlen zu verkünden sondern
das höre gerade das Schöne an der wissenschaftlichen also an der Wissenschaft Ansicht Wissenschaft hat nie in Anspruch die Wahrheit zu wissen sondern Wissenschaft hat immer Diag
aktuell beste Beschreibung der Situation also wir wissen auch dass wir mit der Quantenmechanik unglaublich viel beschreiben können als wir können der Natur sauviel saufen erklären mit der Quantenmechanik aber bei weitem nicht alles also,
quantenmechanischen Gravitationstheorie treffe immer noch nicht so richtig zusammen also zumindest nicht experimentell,
dazu noch bestätigt und auch dazu wenn wenn du einen Physiker fragst du dir auch niemand sagt ja die die Quantenmechanik ist die Antwort auf alle Fragen sollen die Quantenmechanik,
beispielsweise ist halt unsere beste Beschreibung die wir aktuell haben um 3:30 Uhr ginge auf kleinen Skalen in irgendeiner Form zu beschreiben.
Übrigens riesen Unterschied auch zu den eso Spinner die können immer alles erklären die haben immer alle auf alles Antworten dazu auch eine Sache die wir viel zu wenig kommunizieren eigentlich also
bei uns geht's jetzt noch aber so die Wissenschaftskommunikation Ansicht zu sagen wo sind eigentlich gescheitert was hat nicht funktioniert gerade daraus lernst du ja viele Sachen also genau wir ein dass jetzt gerade gesagt hat wo sind unsere Grenzen wofür verstehen wir es noch nicht
Jesolo.
Oder also das dass das was wir haben sind immer nur Modelle also wir haben Modelle
die in gewissen Grenzen das erklären was wir beobachten können oder auch vorher oder Vorhersagen machen können für neue Experimente und wenn wir neue momentan bestätigen eventuell unsere Theorien oder widersprechen der muss man die Theorie ändern aber Wissenschaft hat eigentlich nie den Anspruch eine Wahrheit
verkünden sondern immer nur eine Beschreibung dessen was wir beobachten können und was wir in irgendeiner Form essen können das ist ein großer Unterschied also.
Dazu noch Fragen.
Von uns oder da.
Sieferle wenn du kannst auch was fragen das ist vielleicht ne ich kann auch was beantworten vielleicht.
Du bist gebracht wird.
Ja klar das warum muss ich denn immer nur fragen.
Wir wurden über das gefragt relativ viel gefragt warum wir in diesem Jahr keine Show machen und was wir mit also hier auf diesen auf dieser Veranstaltung keiner wissenschaftsshow machen und wir,
der ist interessant zu es gibt wohl Gerüchte warum wir das nie
ich machen und wir sammeln im Moment Gerüchte und wir werden dann die die die erfolgreichste oder für uns lustigste das lustigste Gerücht werden wir dann kultivieren und wären dann behaupten das wäre.
Aber ich fand das lustigste bisher war irgendwie weil weil ich ja dieses Jahr heirate meine Frau.
Das Gefäß.
Das ist gerade das ist so wunderbar absurd.
Gefällt mir ganz gut.
Das war jetzt keine Frage.
Stimmt ja war keine Frau oh jetzt wieder streng vier Minuten vor Schluss wieder streng mit sein.
Genau fragen du bist voll.
Was was wünscht ihr euch von.
Von UKW.
Nevena nicht voneinander was wünscht ihr euch vom Format Podcast also gibt's den Podcast in ihr euch noch wünscht ins nicht.
Das ist jetzt keine Frage zu dem was du gerade meintest Rainer da war zu zu tim was ist jetzt OKW eigentlich.
Unglaublich kurzweilig.
Also ich habe aufgegeben alles von Anfang an definieren zu wollen,
Dinge ja ist mein ich kann jetzt irgendwas behaupten und am Ende kommt sowieso was anderes bei raus,
ich habe da eine grobe Idee und wenn alle das dann vielleicht begleiten können
ob das so ist so erstmal ein anderer Kanal volevo eine andere Art von Diskussion Stadtviertel sich denkt wer meine anderen Formate kennt wird es vielleicht schon ein bisschen gespielt haben,
oder also so
anderer ichwillmehr einfach konkret und und und und real über irgendwas diskutieren und nicht unbedingt ihr Zimmer nur so diese Erklärbär Welt machen oder so dieses Etwas,
lustige hin und her wie was jetzt läuft bei der Freakshow haben oder so.
Weiß ich schätze den Diskurs generell also das ist mir einfach ein Anliegen und es gibt einen verschiedene Arten und Weisen aber ich denke wenn man einen Podcast Kanal abonniert abonniert man eben nicht nur da,
die man dann empfängt und abhört soll,
verbinde damit eben der Erwartungshaltung und die hat halt was mit den Personen zu tun natürlich ganz klar dass auch ein Auswahlkriterium aber ist eben auch einen Modus in dem man sich auch selber rein geschaukelt hat wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie in eurer Show auf einmal alles ganz anders machen würdet,
dann würde das nicht disruption sein die vielleicht mal zwischendurch mal ganz lustig ist aber langfristig dann nicht greifen würde,
weil man sich halt gegenseitig auch ein wenig einladet und irgendwie gerade was diese
Excel Schleife betrifft ja dann über die Zeit auch ein System geworden ist was funktioniert und so ein System muss halt ja auch erst entstehen und deswegen ist es sehr schwierig für mich zu sagen was,
was wird irgendwas mal sein wenn es irgendwie älter ist als es jetzt ist kann ich nicht so richtig beantworten.
Ich ich hätte zwei kurze Fragen gibt's für UKW schon fit.de nicht abonnieren kann.
Ja den Feed gibt es schon aber bis das iTunes Podcast Verzeichnis den Ausspruch dauert wahrscheinlich noch mal ein paar Tage weil es ja gerade Weihnachten und die Arbeiten alle nicht.
Ja ja aber er aber ich finde das da also ich finde das irgendwann.
Der UKW.
Und und und die nächste Frage wäre du sagtest er erscheint häufig aber nicht nee wie war das manchmal gehst du so eine grobe Idee und wie.
Dass diese Frage von dir kommen.
Ich weiß es ist schön wenn man damit ihm was.
Verlässlichkeit von dir.
Habe ich dich jeden täuscht habe ich dich ernsthaft mal enttäuscht.
Ja bitte also nee nee nee jetzt mal im Ernst also möchte mich zu also hast du eine grobe Idee willst du Kaffee in die so einmal im Jahr machen oder irgendwie wenn du irgend Thema findest was ich gerade beschäftigt oder.
Na ja wie ich will schon sagte nicht regelmäßig aber er öfter als hätten also das will ich jetzt.
Oh da ist es konkret geworden Gott sei Dank.
Was weiß ich wusste ich worüber wir heute reden hat trotzdem funktioniert ja hat.
Jahwe.
So ne so ist es halt keine Ahnung
ich mache jetzt keine commitments oder so ihr werdet ja schon merken ich bin jetzt ein bisschen im Ausland deswegen ist es für mich ganz praktisch ein Format zu haben wo ich mal Dinge auch remote machen kann.
Komm mal kurz EU-Ausland.
Ja Barcelona.
Achso okay ich dachte du willst irgendwie so ich wusste nicht wo Du hin du Barcelona.
Ja was wohl meine Podcast nicht.
Nenne mich ich habe da eine gewisse paclog.
Ja passt schon nein ich werde finden Katalonien weihen und nicht nicht nicht nicht permanent und ausschließlich weil ich zwischendurch auch immer mal wieder ein bisschen durch Deutschland touren muss habe ja noch das ein oder andere zu produzieren aber,
ich verbringe die Zeit halt 10 Grad wärmer und mit anderen Perspektive und freue mich auch auf die,
Begegnung mit anderen Realitäten und anderen Denkmustern die anders auf die Welt blicken da ist ja nicht nur Spanien an sich interessant,
war eben auch speziell dann auch noch diese katalonische Frage die Handtücher immer noch ein Thema ist ist besonderem Zusammenhang mit hier T-Shirt,
brexit was er auch noch nicht komplett durchdekliniert ist von daher passt das für mich,
ja deswegen nenne also nach Britanniens hat sich jetzt nicht so interessant mehr ne also aus der Ferne schon.
Für dich als Deutscher ja nicht.
Ja genau.
So ist das da gibt's so eine Frage.
Eine Frage ganz kurz noch jetzt hast du ein Podcast mit UKW ist das der erste Schritt zum Radio.
Ich weiß was musst du jetzt noch mal genauer ausführen was was was was meinst du damit.
Also broadcast nehmt also in die Welt hinaus senden ohne.
Ein Download Format zu haben.
Nee nee natürlich nicht meines Herrn ist ein Podcast ärgert offensichtliches Podcast ist das soll es auch bleiben ja mir mal alle erzählt habe ihr schon gesagt ne das UKW ja viel mehr Reichweite hat das wegen der nicht den Halt ist einfach so weil man es mehr Reichweite hat und muss ja irgendwie ganz geil sein so ne,
ich hoffe das ist und wie ultra kurzweilig wird,
und vielleicht fahren wir noch ein paar andere schöne Abkürzungen ein die seid ja sehr eingeladen in den Kommentaren Vorschläge zu machen was man aus UKW alles noch machen kann ich hatte das schon mal so eine Liste habe ich aber wieder eingebüßt und,
ja wie immer ich versuche halt Informationen Debatte und ein bisschen Unterhaltung zusammen zu Mengen was kurzweiliges was Spaß macht,
gehört zu werden ja nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger.
Ein wundervolles Schluss.
Sieht aus Nikolaus Reinhard vielen vielen Dank ihr wart die besten Copiloten für den Piloten und ja vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier auf dem Kongress vielen Dank Tschüss bis bald das was.